[Música]
la más grande campana de la catedral de
nôtre dame en parís el burdo nema nivel
rompió su silencio
no había sido tocada desde octubre de
2020 hoy resuena de nuevo en solidaridad
con ucrania
[Música]
la misma escena se repitió en lyon
y también en colonia al mediodía de este
jueves varias catedrales europeas
hicieron sonar sus campanas al unísono
[Música]
las campanas tocaron siete minutos un
minuto por cada día de esa guerra
absurda estamos expresando nuestra
solidaridad con las personas de ucrania
que están aterrorizadas por la guerra
ese día fue muy conmovedor en todo caso
se sintió bien pensamos en toda la gente
que está oyendo alimento en qatar y
staff de flushing
en la capital alemana la catedral de
berlín alzó su voz
un homenaje que se replicó en viena
frente a la catedral santa y tierra
muestras de apoyo en honor a todos los
que perdieron la vida en el frente o
durante los bombardeos en esta primera
semana de combates
[Música]